what's up everyone we are here at e3
2016 I'm Mike McCarty here with Dave
Jewett ok we just saw some Dawn of War 3
and Dave here is a big war hammer fan or
a nerd whichever one you want to say he
says nerd I don't want to insult him but
I like RTS games this is kind of a match
made in Warhammer heaven yeah so Dave
tell us what kind of like story are we
looking at here with Donna for three so
apparently the elder the orcs and the
Space Marines that the Blood Ravens have
been drawn to this planet in search of
an ancient weapon and while evolved in
clone 2 it they're now fighting over it
that's pretty much as much as the dawn
of war guys wanted to tell us at that
point it's we don't know if it's also on
one planet but what we do know is
there's a powerful artifact and
apparently everyone wants it and then we
have these hero units right and these
like super titan units like some of the
biggest that they've ever made can you
tell me about some of those characters
so we've got Gabriel Angelo's who is he
was the captain in the last order for he
is now the chapter master we have lady
Soleri I think her name was who commands
an imperial knight those the two
characters were introduced to but
Gabriel Angelo's is like a tanky
character he's he's a line breaker he
can jump forward and engage in melee and
then the Imperial Knight is just like a
huge towering behemoth just firing the
lead everywhere
yeah gameplay wise the they're really
just going for a different sense of
scale right you have the regular Space
Marines which they were saying even in
their own right it's still like 4 meters
tall or something but then you have
Angelo's and he's this hero unit
Willie's hammer so then he gets even
bigger but then you have you know like
this these titan units right uh lady
Solaria comes down and she's probably
like I think they said like 14 meters
tall yeah so there's the space rains
that are like seven 1/2 feet then
there's angeles's Terminator armor which
is bigger it's dreadnought she's even
bigger and then did appear light is like
yeah man that's good at that just like
double Gatling guns - you know you
activate the ability to just like spread
and it's just
in the map so from a gameplay
perspective it's kind of about like
managing these different scales right
you have these like the Space Marines
kind of like the melee ones jumping into
cover while the bigger units kind of lay
down suppressing fire yeah from a
gameplay perspective it seems like
you're gonna be kind of like trying to
manipulate each of those levels against
the opponent right traditional RTS like
about you know breaking lines and trying
to get behind them you know spread out
fire and everything then in the end you
kind of really get a sense of scale
right the end of demo we saw the orbital
laser comes down it's pretty big at
first for right but then it starts
hitting more Eldar and more Eldar
getting huge and like almost sucking
them up like kind of like anti-gravity
right you've got light it's a real sense
of what these giant futuristic weapons
can do like as you mention the orbital
bombardment cannon the longer it stays
in the field the bigger it gets the more
powerful it gets it starts affecting the
gravity and all the Eldar start floating
up and then we see some of the abilities
that they appear on light Hamish is just
firing rocket pods everywhere and it's
just crushing damage we've got these big
defensive points that are now only
countable really by assault units and
Mellor units so they've got real like
one-two punch where there's different
ways to counter whether you're a soul
for your giant whether you're entrenched
when your melee isn't there's more
strategy I feel than there has been in
previous chronicles right in the demo
they showed us was just pretty much
Space Marines with their really good
units fighting Eldar kind of like the
vanilla Eldar units I'm really excited
to see kind of like what kind of Pacific
Rim situations will play out where those
huge units are just battling each other
because then you know you get the
counter-attacks from different super
units in the cinematic ma'am we did see
a wife leave was a race night which is
that the elder equivalent of the
Imperial Knight okay just get like big
changes to ribbons in them
I'm sure the orcs will have their own
equipment maybe like a Gargan or
something something suitably gross and
cobbled together
what's up so so that's Dawn of War 3 we
did not get to play it at all just a
presentation and interview with game
directors and whatnot but we will have
more news coming out of that halo Wars 2
is another RTS this year at the show but
for more news coming out of those stay
tuned to games.com
we'll see you later
you